hello everyone another day another
lecture wrote an article a couple days
ago I wrote it in a fit of anger I was
upset
I was upset because some false claims
were made as always and their lies and
maybe they're not even nice that's the
worst part maybe these people are being
honest and telling the truth from their
point of view and that's the way they
see it better than lying that's God in
the background there my son I don't know
I don't know if that's better than lying
because it means they're not even aware
that they're wrong know when you're not
even aware that you're I mean if you're
lying you know you're wrong you know
you're cheating and it's very human to
do so and you know I have a lot of
respect for that what are we talking
about
well that's let's go with our first
first prop Sean Carroll he gives a
little talk in Great Britain and
somewhere in England I think it was
London titled the particle at the end of
the universe and he talks about the
Higgs boson guy that won the Nobel Prize
three or four years ago I think now
right
Peter Peter Bose thought I was good
Peter Higgs he wanted for discovering
the Higgs boson or the theorizing about
or whatever
from Bozo the Clown and guess I don't
know boson yeah I guess yeah I used to
know that well go on because it's
supposed to act like glue yeah both ah I
can't remember why but I'm sure we can
look that up real quick so Sean Carroll
gives us presentation why am I upset
well I'm upset because he makes a claim
that many people claim in their blogs on
YouTube you'll see it everywhere how a
magnet works no one on planet earth can
tell you how a magnet works and I'm
talking about the mechanism of
attraction at a distance famously you
can look it up also in youtube you'll
find that mr. Richard Fineman he was
1965 Nobel Prize of mathematics and he
couldn't he was interviewed by the BBC
and he couldn't answer the question he
finally said well you know if you take
the course at the university you know
there's a one understanding and if I
have to explain it to you you know like
to a child ten year old child well you
know I have no simple way of telling you
in other words he had no clue because
math physics is straight forwards
literal you know if I ask you again I
use that example all the time you know
how the window broke you say well you
know the dog jumped through the window
or a rocket through the window and we
all understand that that's how easy it
is it's Rick in der garden and kicking
things physics is for kindergarteners
and to say well you know here's a here's
two magnets right right two magnets pull
these apart and you know they attract
around this I can already feel them
pulling and here they you know they lock
this is the entire system two pieces of
metal and to say well you know I can't
really explain the mechanism of
attraction to you in a way that you
would understand you need to take a
course at the PhD level in order to
understand you know what I you know my
mechanism
I would propose no that's nonsense
that's absolute nonsense what do we have
here we have Sean Carroll he says this
would really offended me
we know how magnets work he was
referring to what is it the Insane Clown
Posse you can look it up there in that
you too you don't click on it because
it's not clickable but you can copy it
or just look for the particle at the end
of the universe and YouTube you'll find
Sean Carroll talking about it anyways he
says we know how magnets work and he was
referring to the insane clown posse that
has this phrase in there one of their
songs saying freakin magnets how do they
work what's the rest of it you know
better yeah that's true they're lying
there they really pissed me off too
because they're going through all this
rigmarole saying you know oh we know but
we can't explain it to you in simple
terms no no they don't know they can't
tell you how a magnet attracts from a
distance and here we're gonna see give
you a quick rundown of what Carol said
you'll see it in my Quora paper as well
we know how magnets work so he was
saying insane clown posse well you know
these four guys are musician what do
they know you know we know how magnets
work we you know the mathematicians we
do have a working scientific
understanding of the esoteric phenomenon
known as the magnet big words major
words it's almost scary right okay so
what does he tell you well he says the
following he says the magnet reaches
across mplet because this is the issue
the issues action at a distance
how does a magnet pull from a distance
right how does it have that an invisible
action in here that's the whole issue
the magnet reaches across empty space
and exerts a force it's on the
refrigerator
oh and the refrigerator exerts a force
back that pulls the two things together
they don't need to touch each other how
is that possible
how does a magnet know that there's a
refrigerator refrigerator nearby that it
should be attached to well I'll tell you
the answer
Oh drumroll you know this guy is gonna
tell us the answer and and that was uh
you know I got my hopes up I said well
maybe you know maybe he does have an
answer who knows you know maybe maybe so
I had to watch the YouTube video because
you know now he picked my interest right
well he starts out by saying that
essentially magnets are action at a
distance since she is the same thing for
gravity as it is for Magnus and he says
Newton's and he talks about Newton now
he comes up with the action at a
distance law for gravity F equals you
know force equals gravitational constant
he didn't have the G there at the time
but mass time fans divided by distance
square right that's his that's his
proposal Newton's proposal and then says
Newton's problem with action at a
distance was actually solved by
pierre-simon Laplace it's a way of
rewriting Newtonian gravity but it's a
way that gets rid of action at a
distance
instead of just thinking about you know
random forces between objects very very
far away imagine there's a field filling
the universe ok so now we have a field
you know filling all of space I guess
and in a way that's I've got a lot of
problems with that already to start with
because this means that the space is
what is is a balloon space is a box
cylinder and field whatever the field is
occupies it all all the way to the edge
or is the field infinite together with
infinite space meaning you know what is
space then you know I mean if it's
infinite's nothing so we have a problem
there but let's concede that
let's just concede for the sake of our
email case so the field occupies all of
space okay well will can see that
despite our objections and so what does
he do well essentially I try to put it
into an illustration here you have the
universe and now we're gonna make the
field appear and it's here in green okay
so you can see all the field so here you
have the universe again I'll see you
guys put it up there here's the here's
the universe right and we're gonna put a
field in it we're gonna make it visible
the field is exists throughout all of
space throughout the entire universe and
that's all those green dots so what is
he talking about what is a field
according to you know mr. Carroll here
he says this is his definition
essentially he defines he says what that
means mathematically it's just that at
every point in space there's a number
the number the value of the field okay
so he's saying that field is a bunch of
numbers a value of the field at every
point in space so field is a value at
every point in space or a value of the
field at each point in space it's kind
of you know circular and we'll concede
that as well will overlook the fact that
uses a synonym but essentially he's
saying there's a value at each point in
space okay and he says the way it works
now he's gonna explain the mechanism the
way it works is that near the birth this
curve is a value of the gravitational
potential field it's pushed down by the
earth then it climbs up smoothly and the
gravitational force that in object feels
is just the slope of that line so he's
got a curve right he's gonna put the
slope of the line there he says that's
the gravitational force at that point at
the square the slope meets the curve
right the amount by which the rate at
which the gravitational potential field
is changing
okay so he's got a curve and put this
out so you can see what I'm talking
about
with my hands he's got a curve and so
here here's the curve here's the curve
right and he'll put a slope there and he
says you know the slope tells us the
rate at which the gravitational
potential is changing in other words the
force at that point changes to the next
point to the next point to the next
point and so on okay that's so far
description so far I don't see a
mechanism I can't see what's causing
this thing all I'm saying all there's
all he's doing is saying look this field
thing thingy is a bunch of numbers and
those numbers mean to follow meaning
that there's a potential at each one of
those points stronger as you get towards
an object farther away as weaker as you
get farther away so if you get closer to
a magnet like in this case here right if
you get closer you get stronger and when
you get farther away the you know here
here I don't I personally don't feel any
poor I gotta get closer like over here
there that's where that's where the
weight is strong looking stronger that's
a good the numbers number the number
gets stronger both right more or less
because I mean so far he hasn't
mentioned any objects all he's saying
what is a field a field is a bunch of
values a bunch of potentials a bunch of
numbers with units attached behind it if
you're talking about
Magnus you're probably talking about
Gauss if you're talking about gravity
you're talking about you know force so
so we're talking about different units
here different units of measure he calls
all over the field and he says it just
gets stronger towards the object weaker
farther away okay fine so far we have no
mechanism okay being partly because
there are no objects involved so far he
hasn't mentioned any objects that's
doing the media
so he finishes his present end that was
his presentation you missed it if you
didn't get it you missed it and here's
his recap he's saying so there isn't
anything
acting's instantaneously and spookily at
a distance there's a smooth change from
the position of the earth to the
position of the moon and in this case
he's referring to gravity right the
gravitational potential is very low here
near the earth and it climbs upward as
you go toward the moon and that change
keeps going on forever because the field
occupies all of space all of the
universal okay and the universe is
obviously infinite right I would assume
so the earth is affecting something that
stretches throughout the entire universe
the gravitational potential field that's
the some thing
there's nothing acting instantaneously
across a very large distance so he's
talking about something and nothing the
field is something in one case then he's
saying the field is nothing he's saying
that there's no thing acting at a
distance but he is essentially using the
field as that something he's saying
that's the something that is between two
objects the field and so what is the
field is it a physical object like a
table of dog a tree a rock no a field is
just a bunch of numbers and those
numbers say that it gets stronger
towards the object and weaker farther
away that's it and so we have no
explanation so far we have no
justification for what causes either
gravity or magnetic attraction right and
the punchline he fills it in before but
I like part of the punch line or the
corollary because he says the following
and here you see how they play around
with they know and they don't know they
know they don't know they know they
don't know do you know yes we do know
but do you really know well we don't
really know but we do know and here it
is Newton was very worried that this
phenomenon
action at a distance made no sense
though it was part of his theory much
like contemporary physicists think about
quantum mechanics an incredibly
successful phenomenology you had to put
that sales pitch in there right a set of
rules that fits the data
- wonderful precision and yet deep down
in our bones we think it makes no sense
we can't quite make sense of it so so we
got all these contradictions first he
didn't explain how magnet works or even
gravity then he says look Newton was
puzzled because he says it makes no
sense and he and he as that's like today
the quantum mechanics and they they they
believe quantum mechanics makes no sense
and he's trying to explain how a magnet
works in terms of quantum mechanic here
the field is not the when he talks about
the magnet he's not talking about the
field out there gravitational field
around the earth he's talking about a
little world here you know he talking
about this two magnets right and so he's
talking about the world of quantum
essentially quantum has to explain this
the microworld and what is he saying
he's saying the field you know we can't
explain it we you know it's puzzle it
puzzles us just like it puzzles Newton
and it makes no sense to us but we know
how a magnet works so this is the
problem this is the problem that these
people on the one hand say they know and
the other one they deny and they say
well we don't know everything we're
still investigating or we don't know but
we do know and if you submit a paper to
them they'll reject it on the basis that
they know and you're violating quantum
mechanics so quantum is there to stay in
to deny everything else anyways
this is what he had to explain he had to
explain either either one of these two
cases in the upper case we have two
magnets and all he's saying as the field
gets stronger towards the magnet great
that means that if we illustrate this
each point in space with a
the green dot you will see more green
dots or stronger green dots I put more
higher density but you can think of
these as stronger dots or whatever it's
stronger values at each point near the
magnet and weaker far away I Illustrated
this with density okay so there's
different ways of illustrating this the
bottom picture again rabbit rabbit II
all they're saying is when what is a
field well when you get closer to the
earth there are more dots the density of
dots gets greater or the dots get more
powerful stronger the numbers get bigger
that's all they're saying and when you
get farther away like between exactly
between midway between the earth and the
moon you see fewer dots or less strong
dots
less density whatever you anyway you
want to see it so all they're talking
about is the strength of the field
they're not they haven't told you what a
field is or how the field does it's
magic for example here I have a question
and we discussed this with ants today
and we're gonna deal with this in a
second I'm sure yeah he because he's
strong strong about it you know his
point of view but I'm saying there's a
difference between an explanation any
description all these people did is a
describe that the field gets stronger
towards an object such as a magnet or
two macro objects such as deeper that's
the first one the second issue is that
you know they have not explained a
mechanism and you say okay here we have
a whole bunch of dots let's assume those
are the particles that form the field
assuming a peak of fields made of
particles because that's what a point in
space insinuates suggests if that's what
it is how does a particle pull on
another particle how do these discrete
particles produce attraction between two
magnets or even worse how do they
produce a repulsion because if a field
gets stronger towards a magnet and
weaker farther away why would I turn the
magnet now the now we've got a different
scenario now they push each other away
something is happy
so is the field to field the field the
field is the field always a field it's
just a bunch of dots stronger potential
well here we have a weak or potential in
the sense that you know I mean right now
we can't put these two magnets together
because there's something there
preventing us from putting them together
put north against north or south against
south yeah and that's the issue you know
by saying positive attracts negative
north attracts out we're not we're not
fixing the problem what we're doing is
giving labeled weakened said X attracts
y oh great that's really they're just
labeling or even narrating and so and so
I'm gonna make the invisible visible to
show you what an explanation is and I'm
not gonna say a single word I want you
to look and you'll understand the
mechanism of course I'll put a couple of
words in there so to clarify but I'm
sure you know you can look at this and
say okay like you know if you receive
that you're on another planet
right and they sent uh what was it the
pioneer or one of those or Voyager no no
they sent uh who was it Carl Sagan sent
the plaque some kind to another planet
another he put it on a spaceship they
sent the spent spaceship out of the
solar system I think it was the Voyager
one of those any time capsule yeah and
so they said well maybe this time
capsule arrives at some planet someday
maybe some advanced civilization or even
backward civilization maybe arrive soon
the monkeys are still you know evolving
but the idea is that maybe advanced
civilization you know gets to see this
and gets the plaque in and gets to see
what a Platteville this plaque all the
messages that they put in there in in
mathematical ratios and music and they
put different things in there and they
say Oh hopefully somebody out there sees
this and it'd be so nice for them to see
some of our culture right well imagine
you wanted to send how two magnets
attract each other to another planet
what would you send well if you send
what I'm showing here you can eventually
figure it out you can say okay I pretty
much understand what the name yeah yeah
the the civilization that receives this
can at least figure out okay we don't
understand their language but we can
with with the pictures they show us here
we think we can figure out what they
were talking about what what mechanism
these guys are proposing here's a
mechanism okay yeah first I won't say a
word I want you to stare at it magnetism
yeah this is magnetism
okay I guess we call it a space capsule
yeah you send this to another planet
okay and instead of dividing the magnet
north and south we divide it into top
and bottom upper and lower any way you
want to look at it I use top and bottom
but it doesn't matter the top ones are
swinging the threads clockwise at
counterclockwise the bottom ones
clockwise and as you can see those match
the flow of lines of force through a
magnet in every magnet whenever the
force comes in from the south and exits
the north that's how we label them we
say okay comes in from the south that's
what we'll call the South and they
always exit on the north side and we'll
call that the north as you can see the
green arrows show how the the lines of
force are going in one direction and
coming out the other okay and what are
the little men doing there well you can
see that they're they're twirling the
ropes according to you know the lines of
force yeah and and if they match exactly
the lines of force going through a
magnet and how are we producing
attraction this is the attraction
inversion I have another one for
repulsion but this is the attraction
version well you can see the ropes are
latching on to the other guy's rope and
that's how they're pulling on the other
guy okay
there they're pointing the magnet by
simply interfering with the ropes in
this case from one magnet with the ropes
of the other and as you can see the
north the top is separate from the
bottom okay so if we cut the magnet
instead of north-south you cut it
lengthwise now we can understand how a
magnet attracts another one and again
I'm not here to make people believe in
this
I'm just saying here I have a mechanism
this is what is called a mechanism you
can understand with this mechanism how
magnet could attract another magnet but
that's not what mr. Carroll did what he
did is simply say look the field gets
stronger towards a magnet so what does
that tell me that just tells me how
strong a magnet is it doesn't tell me
what's causing one magnet to be
attracted or repulsed by another doesn't
tell me essentially what he said in my
car cars are cars are fast and they use
up a lot of gas
okay saying all the all the things that
we observe from a car but he's not we're
asking how does the car work yeah and
he's saying okay cars are fast cars use
a lot of gas they expel a lot of gas
from the back everything leaves we've
noticed now we know how a car works yeah
he's just something is what effects the
car does and it's the claim that they
make that oh we know how magnet works oh
we know how a car works and all you did
was say you know the gas goes through
the system and somehow and the wheels
move that's all he said yeah and and if
you put more gas or you press the
accelerator and they move faster that's
all he said and you know that's got
what's that got to do with the mechanism
of how a car works she's not saying what
causes right of the car to move faster
or how the pedaling in the surface
descriptions yeah and I hope you don't
really have little men in your but
anyways I just want to point out here
you have a mechanism whether you accept
it or not is irrelevant the point here
is the the issues for you to understand
what I'm proposing and if you can
understand the mechanism I see what
you're proposing that's it it doesn't
give it any further than that if you
believe it it now we got religion
that's something else yeah
little men jumpy Road that's what cause
they're little I should have put you
know wings and a little halo but you
know but see see someone might say that
and you know they use that argument
against me right there once or twice at
least I'd say yeah well you know I I can
also invent angels I say okay let's see
how do we do it with angels well yeah I
got two angels and they flap their wings
and do this and then they get their
experiences here okay so now we have two
mechanisms we have one with a rope and
one with angels right now do it with
particles according to quantum and
that's where it finishes the discussion
finishes there because you can't do with
particles you can't do it with field a
potential at each point in space you
can't draw another magnet with that
concept
I'll take angels over particles because
no no angels angels I can do because you
know the guy introduces magic that would
be the religious version you could say
but here we don't even have man because
if the angels for example think of this
the angels grab each other's hands they
pull the magnets together by pulling
each other's hands that's one mechanism
now you turn it around now these guys
you know give each other fives and push
each other away so with them I can
understand it with with angel whether I
believe in it or not that's different
but at least I can understand what the
guy is saying please do it with
particles do it with quantum particles
and you you'll you'll die you'll you'll
get lost you'll be you'll be slaughtered
at the conference okay you can't do it
with particles and if a field is a bunch
of particles then you can't do it and if
a field is not a bunch of particles than
what is a field just a value at each
point in space what is
well how do I pull on a magnet with a
value at each point in space well we
talked about this yeah we had a kitchen
war mathematical physicist medical
scientists kind of aren't they're not
interested in the Y or causes of things
they're more interested in the effects
of things things that we measure the
things that we can observe let's make a
list of every like take gravity for
example what are all the properties of
gravity ask themselves if something's
this big has this much pull oh yeah
everything pulls on each other they're
not interested in how everything pulls
on each other they're interested how
much how much is everything influenced
let's write down all the properties that
this gravity phenomenon has so that we
can use it as a tool maybe because
there's no tool use in knowing how a
magnet works there's the tool use in
knowing how much effect a magnet has on
things you know you can do a whole bunch
of I mean take my my headphones are made
with magnets right they don't know how
it's done it was just a trial and error
right near this list of properties the
magnet has they just kind of played
around with later on what the property
is to get this specific effect so that I
can listen to things on the on the
computer and with these headphones but
you know you don't have any any any
technology or use or anything out of
knowing how the magnet works exactly so
they're just really interesting how much
does the magnet work and maybe that's
geared to some degree towards technology
in other words they go to the lab and I
know because you know I worked quite a
few years in in labs and you go to the
lab you run an experiment and you come
up with a number you come up with some
value okay for example you you can try
Magnus you can try electricity and you
can measure that and say okay there's so
much electricity when I do this this and
that and you can measure that create a
graph you can create a trend you can say
okay now I know what happens when I do
this over here for example the bus lines
aluminum bus lines in
in circuits right semiconductors you
make them thinner you make mitre you
know how much current runs with wider
with thinner with more voltage less
voltage so you can map all that you have
all these curves and so now you have the
equation because you say ok this is what
happens here this is what happens there
and now you create a table and you and
you have an equation you say ok I mapped
it completely now you don't have to run
the test again now you can go in there
and look at the graph look at your chart
and say ok let's see I want the device
they have so much voltage or to have so
much current at this point how why do I
have to make the bus line how thick how
you know you looked for the
specifications for what you need for
your target and since you already done
all your testing and you get the
equation you have to grab so you have to
do is pinpoint that and say ok my next
device so when I'm designing right that
one I'm gonna make it thinner here wider
here you modify it because you already
know what you're looking for because you
tested it not because you know how it
works you don't know anything still
about what's happening about current you
don't know how what electricity is you
don't know what a magnet is or how
magnets work or you know all you know is
that you measured and you create it an
equation you created graphs you map the
whole thing and now you can pinpoint
said work right now we're over here we
want to be over here we want it faster
less current smaller devices ok that's
where we need it and that's how the next
group of technology is developed and
it's got nothing at all to do with
science it's got to do with trial and
error put it into an equation map it and
now you know look for your optimal point
the next optimal point that you're
seeking and the interesting part is that
you do the device you design it do you
think you just go and sell it no you
take it back to the lab and test it
because you know theory is one thing and
reality is another and so they say ok
theoretically we're in the ballpark but
now let's test the device be sure
yeah and they test the device and they
find out that it doesn't work or that it
might have problems they go back and
forth until they get it right
trial and error finally they zero and
say okay we get it within the limits
that we want it now that device is a
sellable device and now we manufacture
it
that's the process he knows how to use
it doesn't work well he did at you if I
bring it they don't know all the
intricacies of I mean forget the
explanation of what electricity is just
the explanation of how the cell phone
works on a circuitry level like there
are people in manufacturing who know how
that works how a cell phone works at
least on the macro level of you know
where electricity goes it's not what
electricity is right but where it goes
but people like the layman doesn't even
know that they even just know but they
do know how to use the phone right
that's kind of the technology or the
science part where people know how to
use things but they don't know how
things work
I got a simpler case everybody knows how
to press the button to turn the lights
on not too many people know why or how
that magic occurred and those who know
how that magic occurred because they
know the wiring they don't know what
electricity is they think it's a bunch
of balls you know little beads going
rolling from one atom to the other but
that uses Bohr's planetary model that
means the electron bead is separate than
the proton bowling ball and what keeps
them together so you got to start with
the atom you got to show me your atom
before you can talk about rolling beads
and and they can can't do that they know
one can draw an a hydrogen atom on
planet earth nobody's bringing it back
to magnetism
notion happy mastery over magnetism this
phenomenon we call magnetism is really
determined by knowing that it can be you
how it can be used knowing everything it
can be used for as opposed to know how
the magic actually works if we know
exactly if we can predict basically
exactly how every magnet behaves or what
effects it has we consider ourselves
having mastery over magnetism we know
how magnets work is like if I have a dog
and I know everything the dog can do it
will do you say okay I know that dog you
don't really know you know how the
muscles are moving like the lower levels
right right you don't know that what the
nitty-gritty that gets the dog to do
those things with magnetism it's like
every us fight with knowing how to get
use out of magnetism and and or
predicting how it will behave or how
it'll affect things they don't care
about anything else about the the ropes
they don't care about the how they just
play the balls cuz it's a it's easy to
talk about they could a little instead
of talking about particles they could
have just talked about X x y&z this X
affects that Y and hits the Z they don't
care about those things you just care
about
about a dog I was thinking about a lion
I love lions and imagine a lion you can
measure how fast it runs you know you
can clock it and and so you can you can
know many things about a lion you know
its behaviors how it behaved what's
gonna do in that sense because there are
certain things that are repeatable in
their behavior but that doesn't mean
that you can tell me what's going inside
his body how electricity magnetism how
they'll flow of chemicals all the things
going on inside the lion's head and tail
you know you can't tell me that because
we don't know that much about you know
what goes on inside a one of those
animals you can't we don't even know
about humans you know we can't no one
can tell me exactly you know how the
flow of energy as if we called it is
inside my body I think the best example
would have to be fire oh that's true
yeah fire for the longest time we just
we know how it works the end results
appear almost uh and I'm sure they
didn't go to college to learn you know a
lot of math just to find out how what
fire was the Greeks the Greeks talked
about the four elements and one of those
was fire thing that we know how to use
we don't know how we don't know that it
would I mean now we don't know exactly
because we're so kind of the fringes of
our knowledge always end up at the
atomic level because then when you try
to picture oh yeah it gets kind of
tricky but like we get pretty far in our
knowledge is fine we basically know how
fire works and what it is it isn't this
thing it's just a process but we've been
using it as a technology I was saying
the Greeks the Greeks you know they were
baffled by a fire and it's interesting I
was thinking just now for a second that
were more concerned about fire which
they named as one of the elements and
here was magnetism and they say you know
they knew about lodestone and they knew
that they created you know attracted
their Spears and their swords and they
said Jesus you know there's this force
that attracts from the distance and it's
like you know it's earth fire wind and
water and you say well what about
magnetism what's the force here and
that's I guess when they came up with
the ether you know when they saw this
kind of stuff that they couldn't answer
they said well that's the ether at the
fifth element you know an invisible
element of some kind that's the one we
we have as a spirit inside us also you
know that kind of thing but you know
they they were concerned about fire they
didn't know what fire was and so they
said it's an element it's a standalone
element all on its own we'll call it
fire because they were fascinated you
know what is fire it's just because they
use for fire they used in their daily
life but they didn't know what it was
right and they were fast they weren't
talking about electricity that's
interesting because they didn't he had
no use for electricity no one was using
it then so they had no no nobody was
using it then well how about what
knowledge is well how about no no no no
how about when that lightning came in
down they said oh my god what is that
yeah but the question is what did they
think of that but it's not in their
everyday you know waters and everyday
fires in their daily life wondering what
they thought about when they saw this
this thing from heaven yeah they must
have thought it was the gods for sure
but I'm saying yeah but I mean then what
is that thing I mean we have fire we
have earth we have water but you
understand those because we can touch
them we can see them in the air but we
never see we can never touch it but we
can see this thing when God gets mad you
know Zeus when he gets pissed off he
sends us that maybe killed someone on
earth well what is that and they
probably knew that it could kill maybe
they saw someone when it's that loud you
got a suspect that he can kill someone
right no no no - I ever saw one nest of
black and I know
you never saw someone die in front of
you just kind of going like if he wants
to kill you they'll kill you but but
then the question is what what did they
think of this Thunder of this but that's
my point since it wasn't a technology
that they worked with every day so it's
kind of in the back burner magnetism
yeah it was nice for philosophers not
for our technology's virginity never
used like magnetism in war for example
if they had some very powerful use for
it then they would have investigated
more they thought more about it Oh
interesting
who cares yeah it was an interesting
phenomenon but it's not like we needed
for anything in fact they didn't use of
magnets ray they I mean they could have
used it if they knew they could have the
electromagnets or whatever pulling
things up heavy things could have pulled
their ships right off the ocean or
whatever but it never occurred to them
that they could use that magnet to do
something useful that are not used for
technology yeah it's just fascinating
you know I like plasma plasma ball you
know it's it's nice to watch but it
serves no purpose just just Beauty
fascination with the effect with a with
a phenomenon but there's you know what
am I gonna do with a plasma ball play
bowling you know what am I
alleviates you know no no quality of
life effect right it's just interesting
and you know pet rocks they're
interesting I guess for some people but
no Barresi you can't turn off so there's
no point talking about Hills it's kind
of Universal no one really thought about
gravity is like a technology oh yeah no
but but we have violated gravity I mean
balloons the airplanes we've tried to
file a we know that gravity does bad
things to it when we fall from the
mountain we sent out can we prevent that
will create a balloon and you go up
against gravity or that kind of thing or
instead in fact I'm sure a lot of people
even from the days of the grease you
know they were fascinated by birds the
fact that they could violate gravity and
the story of Daedalus and his honey
Karis you know is specifically designed
for the study of birds they were
concerned or they were wondering oh it'd
be nice to fly you know they put wings
on Pegasus just so he could fly you know
a horse that flies you know they they
were fascinated to some degree with that
but they had no use for it because they
never thought they could by themselves
the doors wide open we can teleport we
can go back in time we can go through
the fourth dimension they I can talk to
- Bugs Bunny i conductor my
great-grandfather know guys millions of
years ago my great-grandfather I always
talk everybody doesn't talk back he yeah
he's a nice guy you know I'm talking to
like Indiana Jones
you can't yeah yeah he's not real and
that's kind of the Superman through
fourth dimensions just you you can't
even do that I just it's like driving
through the banana dimension but some
people sometimes only Donna but some
people might believe that they can go
through the bananas I mentioned and dr.
Superman I mean for all we know and some
of these people you would think they're
rational and they seem normal but then
they come up with some questions some
people have told me that they believe
that humans can do anything and so I
have to invent you know some weird thing
like and can they go through the fourth
dimension can they go see and and they
insist we can do anything and they
really believe this because they go to
Hollywood and they watch movies and they
say yeah look I saw it in the movie we
can do anything do you believe in a way
I don't know if it's hope so much or
maybe it's a combination of hope no no
no I'm saying and a lot of
indoctrination through through movies
where they do so many flashy effects
that people start believing that well
you know Hollywood can do and we can
imagine it then something we're gonna
develop this technology and we're gonna
be able to do it it's like you know the
famous case everybody always throws in
my face is the but as a 19th century
French guy
I always forget his name yeah Jules
Verne and Jules Verne said you know
which the moon voyage around the world
in 80 days
and people say this guy's an idiot you
know he he's dreaming and then we were
able to produce that technology people
say see we just burn those days they
thought he was crazy but then he had the
technology to do that we could go around
the earth in 80 days and even faster and
and we went to the moon yeah we have to
throw the yeah but they'll say it's just
a matter of time you know we'll build
this tunnel all the way to the center
and we'll we'll just drop you in there
and you you know they don't know this
but the point here is that people get
these things in well you know everybody
thought that Jules Verne was crazy and
then we were able to do it in the same
way we'll be able to go through the
fourth dimension we'll be able to travel
to the next Galaxy over they think that
all these things are possible because
they saw it in the movie they saw Star
Trek they saw The Twilight Zone and they
were convinced that you know we can do
anything and that's the problem the
problem is these people are in the air
with their feet they're there no longer
will the feet on the ground
reinforcing anyways the point here was
that there is no explanation from the
mathematical establishment on how two
magnets work wherever you see anywhere
on the internet anywhere whether it's
YouTube whether you go to a blog or you
go to a chat given by people like Sean
Carroll here a talk on magnetism and
gravity and who knows what action at a
distance they don't have a mechanism
mechanism you just saw mechanism this is
the mechanisms I'll put it up one more
time just so what is the mechanism well
here's a mechanism a mechanism means
that I can show you
mechanically mechanically right what
you're looking at something mechanical
right there that I put it back up here
you have a mechanical representation of
how a magnet could possibly attract
another one
okay that's uh yeah because again that's
what mechanical is I could do it I could
also do a movie and I can also go to the
lab and maybe reproduce it in some form
and make a macro right right I could I
could put two boxes I could put two
boxes and have two people skip over them
you know I can do that kind of thing
maybe but the point here you see a
mechanist
what is the mechanism the mechanism
spinning ropes and the ropes interfere
with each other and they attract why is
this plausible because the swinging of
the ropes matches exactly the entrance
of the lines of force in the South
Region and out the north and if you take
the north guy and you take that I'm
sorry you take the guy in the top you
take the guy in the bottom they exactly
match that pattern you know what I think
about the skipping-rope you know how you
twist it or turn it right one from the
other if you follow in your mind really
need a good 3d programmer for this if
you follow in your mind how the jump
Roper is turning with it I did they
always face yeah did you see the yeah
but it's always hard it's 2d yeah it's
2d but the point is you know I try to
illustrate as best as possible and I do
turn the magnet in one direction then in
the north-south direction and you can
see that all matches all of our matches
jump ropes nice nice oh so in that sense
all you can say is it's a plausible
explanation because it's a mechanism
that matches what we observe with
magnets and also that becomes like okay
what are these jump ropes or who are the
right people do which is the second
digit right what's happening let's get
the mechanism and what I'm saying here
Sean Carroll he doesn't have a mechanism
all he says it's the field what is a
field a bunch of numbers and how do you
attract two magnets with numbers you
can't do you hear yeah you're just
saying they just do it it's stronger the
closer it is so they're just meandering
the intensity of the field they're not
giving you a mechanism they can't
illustrate it for sure they can't do a
particle quantum particles not even
saying why it does correct and and
that's another issue you know you got to
do quantum light like I said a minute
ago I can do it with angels you know and
I can say the Angels you know grabbed
each other's
and pull the magnets together and that's
how they attract and then when they turn
around
you know they push each other away with
their hands and I can do it with angels
not whether you believe that theory
whether you believe that mechanism
that's individually there yeah but I
mean some people might might say that a
car runs because the Angels move the
wheels I mean they could do that God God
moves everything that I'm saying at that
point it's not like we're done with
science at that point the person who's
listening to really understand it would
have to ask questions about the
assumptions at least we have a starting
point yeah question yeah yeah we're with
angels at least we can we can start a
discussion say well I mean you know why
do the Angels hit each other's hands and
you can ask a bunch of questions with
quantum mechanics you don't even have a
starting point there isn't it they can't
even illustrate how a bunch of particles
discrete particles it between two
magnets attract each other and that's
why they never do that you know these
things are settled in high school they
say look a magnet attracts another and
Michael Faraday did a million
experiments James Maxwell put it in
equations and then we forgot completely
about the 19th century we don't deal
with magnets anymore but specifically at
the university level we don't deal with
that kindergarten stall they don't know
because they can't add well because they
cannot explain the mechanism of two
magnets and then you have these people
like Sean Carroll talking about oh yeah
we know how magnet works you do well
please explain it buddies explain the
mechanism and that's when they say well
we don't there's many things which are
surprising that you know they're not
common sense according to it yeah
they're counter to to use all these
terms and then they say but we know well
if you know please explain if you don't
know please say that you don't know
though don't don't use that duality
where you say we know and then we don't
know
we no no but we're still investigating
yeah or we need more funds to you know
to smash more particles to find out how
it works no forget it you can't explain
it with the field you're trying to find
a cure for that disease you know you
need a result you need you need to care
the kid you can't just say oh we're
still investigating and there's no
excuse you can give the kid that'll help
him the kid wants the answer yeah can
you solve this please and you can't say
we know and then you can then and then
not do that yeah yeah yeah the point is
you know here they don't have a
mechanism and again you can say well you
know I can come up with angels with God
with spirits yeah fine no problem if you
can explain it with angels I'll accept
at least your explanation when we go
into the questioning phase but the point
here is that quantum mechanics with
particles with their famous field they
cannot explain the mechanism you know
you just put whatever you want instead
of a field if a field like like Sean
Carroll says every particle has a field
and that field extends throughout the
universe that's the way they pay they
covered all the bases they said look
every particle a muon a Payan and
electron all of them have a field and
that field extends throughout the
universe both magnetic and electric so
they covered the whole thing okay fine
right so yeah and so now we have that as
the foundation fine okay so you have
this particle now put that particle
between two magnets please explain how
North attracts out with that yeah they
simply can't do it you can't do it with
particles and that's where quantum
mechanics fails it's a non-starter
because it's a discrete particle theory
and discrete particles cannot explain
attraction what if period boom done with
they say something like it's inherently
unimaginable so the mechanism is
unimaginable so let's not that's not
there is no physical object that we can
put in there that would explain all this
so let's not bother with that it's
things like philosophy we don't care
about that part here's some there's some
merridy introducing spirits ya know
because that's essentially by default
imagine it by default they're
introducing spirits because one thing is
to say look I don't know and another one
is to say they're like Sean Carroll said
here he said there is let me read it
because it's it's pertinent here oh here
it is
he says so there isn't anything acting
instantaneously and spooky at a distance
there's a smooth change from position of
the earth to the position of the moon
the gravitational potential is very low
here near the earth and it climb blah
blah blah so the earth is affecting
something that stretches throughout the
entire universe he covered all the bases
covered the entire he painted the whole
entire universe with this field the
gravitational potential field
there's nothing acting instantaneously
across very large distance
so essentially what he's saying is look
we have spirits we call spirit we call
the spirit field okay and this spirit is
throughout the entire universe and this
spirit is what produces attraction and
the way it produces attraction and has a
different value at different points in
space stronger near the objects we don't
know why a weaker farther away but it's
a spirit and that's what a field is it's
a spirit that's all it is but I'm sure
you've dealt with this argument
where someone says ok what if there is a
phenomenon that we just can't imagine
like the mechanism is just unimaginable
we can't even like play a movie oh it's
just crazy yes well that's where were
you clash against the guy like Bill
Gates
you know because Bill giddy now has a
mechanism yeah so I have a mechanism
they don't I have a physical mechanism I
have a physical mechanism for gravity
they don't they say it's a field and
what's the mechanism well we don't we
don't know we can't figure out what the
field what the field is on a man and
it's not a thing but it is a thing
because that's what we use in math to
bring two things together just the
potential and you said but you don't
have a mechanism I do yeah so so if the
if the Christian or the Muslim comes
over and says well I can do it with
angels fine come bring your angels in
let's hear you and the guy says you know
they they clash hands against each other
and they push each other away when they
want to pull they pull each other ok I
understand your mechanism essentially
what you're saying is is that the
unimaginable leti argument dies yeah
there's no excuse that you never heard
about it and the best you have are these
crazy Fields seals and whatever then in
the back your mind you you're either
frustrated and you don't you know press
the question further or you just kind of
give up and say it's unimaginable so I
won't bother with that right but now if
someone comes and tells you about the
Rope hypothesis not in a douchey way
like you kind of like to do it we're not
a nice way and kind of you know them on
board I think I'll use this right now
and then it'd be a different issue and
you can't really talk about unimaginable
attea yeah now you get a competitor you
get a competitor and and you know
quantum has to meet that challenge
because quantum cannot come up with a
mechanism they don't have a physical
mechanism of physical interpretation for
magnetism or bravi
and and now they have won and so now
that now they do have something against
which to run against yeah if someone
says it's unimaginable you throw this in
their face how about this Here I am
imagining it and they can question so
well but to invent that the road yeah
okay fine but you you can understand the
mechanism I don't have a mechanism from
quantum mechanics with all their
particles you can't produce attraction
with them and that's the issue
anyways tomorrow same time same station
we'll see you then
and probably another subject we'll see
you bye